[Music]
humans and machines have been merging
for thousands of years right now I'm
wearing shoes I have a microphone on my
jacket we all probably use our phones at
least once a day and we communicate with
the augmentation of all sorts of
amplification and even translation
technologies you can speak into a
machine and we'll translate the words
you're saying in nearly real time so I
think what might be different in the
years to come is a matter of degree not
a matter of kind one concept that I
think is emerging is what I like to call
the brain coprocessor a device that
intimately interacts with the brain it
can upload information to the brain and
download information from it imagine
that you could have a technology that
could replace lost memories or augment
decision-making or boost attention or
cognition to do that though we have to
understand that how the brain works at a
very deep level although over a third of
a million patients have had brain
implants or neural implants that
stimulate the nervous system
so far they've operated in an open-loop
fashion that is a drive activity in the
brain but not in a fully responsive
fashion what we want to do is have
bi-directional communication to the
brain can you read and write information
continuously and supply maybe through
coupling these interfaces to silicon
computers exactly the information the
brain needs my hope is that over over
the next five to ten years we're going
to get deep insights thanks to our
technologies and to how brain circuits
compute and that will drive the design
of these interfaces so that we can
deliver information to the brain and
record information from the brain using
the natural language of the brain
reading and writing information in a way
that augments for example the number of
things you can hold in your mind at once
or the ability to recall famous nearly
perfectly which is you know not an
ability so different from looking
something up on a search engine on your
phone right so I think what's going to
happen is a continuation of this trend
and I think a lot of people like to talk
about artificial intelligence right now
artificial intelligence as it stands is
based on a lot of concepts that go back
many decades that build from some very
simple observations about the brain what
might a I do though once we
of incredibly deep insights into the
nature of creativity and ethics and
other things that the human brain seems
to be uniquely equipped for I think once
you start to couple artificial
intelligences to the brain that can
really augment these uniquely human
capabilities it leads to a new era of
what you might call hybrid intelligence
so it won't just be AI running away and
some positive feedback loop
it won't be humans upgrading themselves
in the absence a couple into the world
but I think it'll yield a new kind of
symbiosis and I think that's probably
the best possible path and it's also
already if you look at how people
operate in the world what seems to be
one of the most prevalent models
[Music]